On l'appelle le berceau de l'humanité,
creuset de la civilisation.
L'occident lui doit beaucoup
des fondements de sa culture.
Des milliers d'années n'ont pas eu de prise sur
la qualité des trésors d'art et d'architecture,
Légués par ces populations antiques.
C'est l'Égypte.
Égypte, Terre de civilisation.
Situé aux portes de l'Afrique,
au carrefour de trois continents,
L'Égypte est bordée au nord
par la mer Méditerranée,
et à l'est par la mer Rouge.
L'Égypte vie d'une île qui l'a
traverse de part en part du sud au nord.
Un fleuve de 6670 kilomètres de long.
Sa source la plus reculée, jaillit au
Burundi, juste au dessus du lac Victoria.
Elle donne naissance au Nil Blanc, qui
rejoint à Khartoum le Nil Bleu,
Née du lac Tana en Éthiopie.
Leurs eaux s'écoulent lentement
jusqu'au nord du Caire.
Pour s'élargir en un delta de près
de 200 kilomètres de large.
Et trouver enfin accès à la Méditerranée.
Ce fleuve conditionne en Egypte
toute forme d'existence.
Au delà de ces rives ne s'étend
qu'un implacable désert,
Plongé dans une chaleur accablante.
Parcouru par des vents de sables brûlants
et souffrant d'une sécheresse endémique.
Ne s'accroche ici que quelques rares espèces
de plantes et d'animaux parmi les plus sobres,
et les plus résistants.
Quant à l'homme, seule la proximité du fleuve
et de ses eaux fécondes,
Lui permet de survivre.
Et sur ses rives, depuis la nuit
des temps, l'homme a survécu.
Et y a prospéré.
Les premières traces de vie humaine
organisées relevées dans cette région,
remontent à l'âge paléolithique.
L'homme alors était nomade.
Il vivait de cueillette et de chasse.
Entre 6000 et 4000 ans avant Jésus-Christ,
Les populations locales
commencèrent à se sédentariser.
Elles asséchèrent les marais pour
y pratiquer la culture et l'élevage.
Elles furent à cette époque rejointes par des
tributs venus d'Asie Mineure et d'Afrique du Nord.
De cette fusion ethnique sont issus
les premiers véritables ancêtres,
des Égyptiens d'aujourd'hui.
Dès 4000 avant Jésus-Christ,
la région est florissante.
Ses habitants vivent dans des huttes
faites de boue séchée et de joncs.
Doté d'un mobilier
relativement confortable.
Le bétail engraisse,
les récoltes sont abondantes,
la pêche est généreuse,
le commerce prospère.
Les artisans produisent des poteries,
des outils, des bijoux.
Tout cela a été notamment révélé
par l'étude des objets familiers,
Qu'ils avaient coutume d'enterrer
avec leurs morts.
Deux royaumes distincts
se sont alors formés.
La Basse-Égypte dans le delta du Nil,
et la Haute-Égypte,
Dans l'étroite vallée qui serpente
vers le sud, sur le fleuve navigable,
Jusqu'aux cataractes d'Assouan.
L'histoire de l'Égypte pharaonique
se divise en trois périodes.
L'ancien, le Moyen et le Nouvel Empire.
Séparés par des périodes intermédiaires.
Des époques de troubles
sociaux et politiques,
De désordre et d'instabilité.
Sur le site d'Abydos une liste établie
au IIIᵉ siècle avant Jésus-Christ,
Par le prêtre Manéthon regroupe en 30
dynasties les règnes qui se sont succédés,
Durant ces trois empires.
L'histoire de l'Égypte débute réellement
vers 3000 ans avant Jésus-Christ,
Lorsque Narmer, souverain de Haute-Égypte,
impose son autorité à son voisin du Nord,
La Basse Égypte.
Ils fusionnent les deux nations
et fondent la première dynastie.
Narmer installe sa capitale à Memphis.
À la frontière des deux territoires
désormais réunis.
Il impose au nouveau pays une stricte
unité politique et militaire.
Il le dote aussi d'une économie prospère
dont bénéficient toutes les classes de la société.
Dès lors, se développe très vite un
important foyer de civilisation.
En 30 ans de règne et avant d'être
emporté, dit la légende, par un hippopotame,
Narmer forge du roi,
une image de Dieu vivant,
Qui restera acquise à ses successeurs
au fil des siècles.
À l'origine, les souverains égyptiens étaient
désignés suivant une antique formule,
confiant le pouvoir au gendre
de la précédente reine.
L'inceste était fréquent,
Afin que les fils puissent pallier
l'éventuelle défaillance,
Ou la disparition du père.
Aha, succéda à Narmer.
On lui attribue quelques conquêtes et la
construction du palais de Memphis.
À l'époque déjà, les Égyptiens
utilisent une écriture figurative,
Qu'ils gravent dans la pierre
ou reproduisent sur des papyrus.
Du nom d'une plante abondante
sur les bords du Nil.
Le procédé consiste à former des feuilles
en pressant plusieurs épaisseurs,
De fines bandes tirées de sa tige.
Cet ancêtre de notre papier
est malheureusement fragile.
Il brûle facilement et souffre de l'humidité.
On croyait le sens de l'antique
écriture égyptienne définitivement perdue,
lorsqu'en 1799, le capitaine Bouchard,
un officier qui participait à
l'expédition de Bonaparte en Égypte,
découvrit à Rosette une
petite ville proche d'Alexandrie,
une stèle de basalte qui portait une inscription
rédigée en trois écritures différentes.
Cette pierre de Rosette fut confiée
à divers savants qui tentèrent en vain,
de la déchiffrer.
Finalement, c'est un Français,
Jean-François Champollion,
Qui, 23 ans plus tard,
trouva la clé de l'énigme.
La stèle était mutilée, mais grâce au fait
que l'une des langues de l'inscription,
Était parfaitement connue, on peut
très vite déterminer la nature du texte.
Il s'agissait d'un décret
promulgué à Memphis par Ptolémée V,
en 196 avant Jésus-Christ,
longtemps après la conquête
de l'Égypte par les Hellènes,
Et donc très logiquement rédigé en grec,
À destination de ceux qui
administraient alors le pays.
Les deux autres textes étaient gravés
en démotique, langue populaire des Égyptiens,
Et en hiéroglyphes, langue de leurs notables.
En juxtaposant les trois versions,
Champollion réussit par déduction,
à déterminer le sens
de 24 hiéroglyphes de base.
Puis de quelque 700 autres.
En compliquant à l'extrême
cet alphabet imagé,
Les Égyptiens lettrés l'avaient rendu
incompréhensible au commun des mortels.
Dès lors, la langue vulgaire, le démotique,
sorte de sténographie élémentaire,
Finit peu à peu par s'imposer.
Les Égyptiens croyaient fermement en l'existence
d'une nouvelle forme de vie après la mort,
Mais ils ne pouvaient concevoir que
l'âme subsiste sans enveloppe charnelle.
Ils s'appliquèrent donc à perfectionner
leur technique de momification.
Ils n'avaient pas manqué d'observer
les effets conservateurs des sables brûlants,
Et de l'air sec des déserts de Haute Égypte.
C'est donc là qu'ils choisirent d'ériger
les tombes de leurs morts illustres.
Dès la fin de la troisième dynastie,
elles prirent la forme de pyramide.
La première, bâtie en degrés,
est celle de Zoser.
Elle fut construite à Saqqarah,
un site proche de Memphis,
Par le plus illustre des architectes,
le génial Imhotep.
Imhotep avait tous les talents.
Bâtisseur et lettré.
Il était le principal ministre du roi.
Après sa mort, il fut même élevé par le
peuple à la dignité de Dieu de la médecine.
Zoser inaugure en fait
le temps des pyramides.
Sa tombe est à l'origine un mastaba,
un monument bâti sur un seul niveau.
Imhotep le surélève en même temps
qu'il en élargit le périmètre.
Il le hausse de cinq degrés.
C'est littéralement l'escalier qui va
permettre au roi de s'élever vers le ciel.
Plus tard, la chambre funéraire
sera logée au cœur de la pyramide.
Ici, elle est creusée sous sa base,
à 28 mètres de profondeur.
Au siècle suivant,
sous la quatrième dynastie,
Khéops, Khéphren et Mykérinos,
vont se faire construire
les plus célèbres des pyramides,
Celles de Gizeh.
La pyramide de Khéops est la plus grande.
230 mètres de côté, 137 mètres de haut.
Elle est constituée de plus
de 2 millions de blocs de calcaire,
D'un poids moyen de deux tonnes et demi.
Les proportions du monument dénotent,
de la part des bâtisseurs,
des connaissances troublantes.
À sa base, la pyramide est,
à un centimètre près,
parfaitement horizontale.
Ses côtés ayant une inclinaison
de 51 degrés, 52 minutes.
Le rapport théorique hauteur circonférence
est très exactement de pi divisé par deux.
Cette précision suppose de la part
des architectes égyptiens,
une exceptionnelle science mathématique.
Une erreur de deux degrés seulement dans
l'inclinaison des côtés du monument,
aurait entraîné un défaut de
verticalité de quinze mètres au sommet.
Tous ces tombeaux ont été élevés
sur la rive occidentale du Nil,
Là où le soleil se couche.
Les pierres étaient extraites des
carrières de Tourah,
Situées sur la rive opposée
et acheminées par bateau.
Si on en croit Hérodote, 100 000
hommes ont œuvré pendant 20 ans,
À la construction de ce monument immense.
Ce n'était sans doute pas,
comme on l'a cru longtemps,
Des travailleurs forcés.
Mais des ouvriers agricoles recrutés
pendant la morte saison.
La structure de base de la pyramide
ressemblait à celle de Zoser.
On l'entourait ensuite de rampes de
terre le long desquelles étaient hissés,
Les blocs de calcaire destinés
à parachever l'ouvrage,
En lissant en quelque sorte ses quatre côtés.
L'essentiel de ce revêtement extérieur
a été prélevé quelque 1000 ans plus tard,
Lors de la construction du Caire.
Le sommet de la pyramide de Khéphren en
conserve cependant des vestiges significatifs.
À l'intérieur de chaque pyramide, les
architectes prévoient un dédale de couloirs,
qui conduisent à trois chambres funéraires.
L'une d'elles renferme le sarcophage
en granit du roi,
Un granit extrait de carrières
situées loin au sud, près d'Assouan.
Chaque pyramide est reliée par une
galerie à un temple mortuaire,
Bâti au bord du fleuve.
Creusées autour du monument,
Des fosses contiennent des bateaux destinés
au passage du défunt, dans sa vie future.
Khéphren ne se contenta
pas d'une pyramide.
Il fit construire le fameux sphinx de Gizeh
qui, du haut de ses 20 mètres,
Garde fidèlement depuis 4500 ans le chemin
qui conduit à la tombe de son maître.
Le corps est celui d'un lion,
symbole de force et de puissance.
La face reproduit peut-être le visage
de Khéphren lui-même,
Ou peut-être représente t-elle le dieu Horus,
veillant sur l'horizon.
Peu à peu, les Égyptiens en sont arrivés
à consentir plus d'efforts,
Au culte de leurs morts
qu'à celui de leur divinité.
Et de tous les morts,
C'est évidemment le roi qui doit bénéficier
de la gloire posthume la plus spectaculaire.
Son peuple tout entier est appelé à se
mobiliser pour élever ces monuments immenses,
destinés à préserver le souvenir
des actions du pharaon.
Et de lui assurer l'immortalité
la plus confortable possible.
La quatrième dynastie marque
cependant l'apogée de ce gigantisme.
Déjà, la troisième pyramides
de Gizeh, celle de Mykérinos,
est nettement moins volumineuse
que celle de ses prédécesseurs.
Il est vrai que l'époque de sa construction
est aussi celle du déclin de l'ancien Empire.
À la fin de la sixième dynastie,
après un dernier règne prestigieux,
et particulièrement long, celui de Pépi II,
qui meurt nonagénaire,
Le pays est miné par
un excès de bureaucratie,
Et surtout par les ambitions
d'une foule de potentats locaux.
Vers 2180 avant Jésus-Christ,
l'Égypte est plongée dans le chaos.
C'est la première période intermédiaire
qui va durer un siècle et demi.
Les rois se succèdent par dizaines,
au rythme d'un par jour,
Pendant des semaines, dit la légende.
C'est un temps de famine et d'anarchie.
L'empire manque de tomber dans cette
première grande épreuve de son histoire.
Il est sur le point
d'être totalement démantelé.
À l'aube du deuxième millénaire,
l'Égypte retrouve pourtant son unité.
Cette période, qui s'étend de 1991
à 1786 avant Jésus-Christ,
Est connue sous le nom de Moyen Empire.
Elle est essentiellement dominée par
la 12ᵉ dynastie et surtout par Amenemhat 1er,
Qui déplace la capitale de Memphis à Louxor.
Durant ces deux siècles, la civilisation
égyptienne bénéficie d'un essor culturel,
Et d'une prospérité matérielle sans précédent.
Amenemhat II développe les échanges
commerciaux avec ses voisins du Sud.
Amenemhat III, organise l'irrigation
de milliers d'hectares,
Dont la culture augmente considérablement
la production alimentaire,
Et donc le niveau de vie.
Cette richesse ne pouvait manquer
d'inspirer des convoitises.
Des tribus venues d'Asie, les Hyksôs,
S'infiltrent dans le delta.
D'où elles se répandent dans tout
le pays pour en prendre le contrôle.
Leur régime, qui se succèdent
de la 15ᵉ à la 17ᵉ dynastie,
Couvre la deuxième période intermédiaire.
Peuple guerrier, les Hyksôs
introduisent en Égypte le cheval,
le char de combat, les armes en bronze.
Deux siècles plus tard, les princes thébain
reprennent le pouvoir.
Ils repoussent les Hyksôs jusqu'en Palestine,
Et recréent une dynastie indépendante, la 18ᵉ.
Le Nouvel Empire installe sa capitale à Thèbes.
Thoutmôsis 1er et les autres souverains
qui inaugurent cette dynastie,
Pratiquent une politique de conquête
qui vise à protéger le pays,
Et lui garantir sa sécurité.
Ces expéditions les conduiront loin
vers le sud, l'actuel Soudan,
Et vers le nord-Est jusqu'à l'Euphrate.
Thoutmôsis 1er fut le premier
pharaon à ordonner que sa tombe,
Soit creusée dans la fameuse vallée des rois.
Le site est proche de Thèbes,
sur la rive opposée du Nil.
Le paysage est chaotique,
les repères sont rares,
Et c'est ce qui déterminera
le choix du souverain,
Très soucieux de garder sa sépulture
secrète à l'abri des voleurs.
Mais ses successeurs par dizaines
suivirent le même raisonnement,
Si bien que la vallée et sa destination funéraire
n'eurent bientôt plus rien de secret.
On recense aujourd'hui 62 hypogées,
Le nom donné à ces tombes
creusées dans le roc.
Toutes ont été profanées, dont certaines dès
le XIᵉ siècle avant Jésus-Christ.
Toutes sauf une, celle de Toutânkhamon,
Découverte intacte en 1922 par
un archéologue anglais, Howard Carter.
Le pharaon n'avait que 18 ans
lorsqu'il mourut,
Après un règne insignifiant de quelques mois.
Sans doute les pilleurs de tombes
pensèrent-ils que si jeune,
Il n'avait pas amassé de bien grand trésor.
C'est à cette indifférence
que Toutânkhamon doit d'être devenu,
32 siècles après la fin
de sa si courte vie,
Le pharaon le plus célèbre du monde.
La découverte d'Howard Carter,
la tombe de Toutankhamon,
Contenait un trésor d'une richesse
et d'une qualité artistique exceptionnelle.
Le sarcophage renfermait un triple cercueil,
Le premier en bois décoré d'or et d'argent,
Le deuxième couvert
d'or incrusté de verreries.
Le troisième, enfin, de plus de trois
centimètres d'épaisseur, en or massif,
rehaussé de faïence bleue
et de pierres naturelles.
La momie elle-même portait
un masque funéraire sculpté,
Dans une épaisse couche d'or fin.
Une antichambre contenait
une profusion d'œuvres d'art,
De mobilier, de statues, d'armes,
de chars et d'objets utilitaires,
En tout quelque 700 pièces en ivoire, en
albâtre, en bois ou en métaux précieux.
Elles font aujourd'hui
la fierté du musée du Caire,
Où sont également exposés deux des trois
cercueils qui s'emboîtent pour abriter la momie.
Le plus grand a réintégré le tombeau
de la vallée des Rois.
Toutânkhamon y repose à nouveau.
Tel que nous le restituent ses effigies
qu'Howard Carter décrivait tristes et calmes.
Suggérant la jeunesse prématurément
surprise par la mort.
Et s'il est vrai que les voleurs jugèrent
autrefois ces trésors trop modestes,
Pour attirer leur convoitise,
On se prend à rêver en songeant aux merveilles
que devait contenir les tombes qu'ils ont pillées.
Parmi les ancêtres de Toutânkhamon
dans la 18ᵉ dynastie,
Figurent les Thoutmôsis,
deuxième et troisième du nom.
Fils illégitime, Thoutmôsis III était
encore tout enfant à la mort de son père.
Il fut écarté du pouvoir à la
suite d'une révolution de palais,
Alors unique dans les annales de l'Égypte.
C'est sa belle mère, Hatchepsout,
qui s'empara du trône.
Pour justifier cette confiscation, elle
n'hésita pas à s'affirmer la fille de Amon,
Le grand dieu de Thèbes.
Du moins lui doit on l'une des merveilles de
l'architecture égyptienne,
Le temple de Deir El-Bahari,
Construit dans un site proche
de la vallée des rois,
Et consacré à Hathor, la déesse
de l'amour et de la joie.
Il est célèbre pour la beauté
de ses bas reliefs.
Beaucoup illustrent les expéditions
commerciales qui demeurent l'élément marquant,
de ce règne hors du commun
qui dura près de quinze ans.
À la mort d'Hatchepsout,
revenant enfin au pouvoir,
Thoutmôsis III se lança quant à lui dans
une succession de campagnes militaires,
Dont il ramena, dit la chronique,
une profusion de richesses et d'esclaves,
Parmi lesquels beaucoup d'hébreux.
L'égypte touchait à l'un
des sommets de sa puissance.
Les gouvernants des pays proches y envoyaient
leurs fils afin qu'ils s'y instruisent.
Rentrés chez eux en bons élèves,
Ils devenaient les plus sûrs alliés
de leur puissant voisin.
La société égyptienne était
désormais soigneusement hiérarchisée.
Au sommet, le roi, paraît depuis l'avènement
du Nouvel Empire du titre de pharaon,
Qui signifie littéralement le Grand Palais.
Sous l'autorité du pharaon,
des classes sociales en cascade.
Une élite, tout d'abord,
les hauts fonctionnaires,
Les prêtres et les nobles.
Ensuite, une classe moyenne,
Composée des scribes, artistes,
Soldats, enseignants,
commerçants et artisans.
Au bas de l'échelle, les domestiques,
Les paysans et les ouvriers.
Et plus bas encore, mais relativement
peu nombreux, les esclaves.
La richesse du pays garantit à chacun une
relative prospérité et l'ordre règne.
Pourtant, les Égyptiens
manquent d'espace vital.
Ils sont contraints de vivre dans
l'étroite bande de terres cultivables,
Qui court de part et d'autre du Nil.
Leurs maisons s'y entassent
les unes contre les autres.
Les seules demeures solides et confortables
sont celles des nantis.
Elles sont vastes.
Leurs porches monumentaux
ouvrent sur de superbes cours,
Des jardins, des bassins ombragés,
Des dépendances où logent les serviteurs.
Elles sont dotées de meubles splendides en
bois précieux, décorés d'or et d'argent.
Chaises et fauteuils sont
recouverts de tapisseries,
Ornées d'incrustations d'ivoire et d'ébène.
Les lits sont confortables,
Équipés de cordons tressés
qui font office de sommier,
Et de draps en lin finement tissés.
C'est de lin aussi
que sont faits les vêtements,
Essentiellement une sorte
de pagne pour l'homme,
Et une longue robe pour la femme.
Les domestiques préparent dans
leur propre logement la nourriture,
Qu'ils servent ensuite à leurs maîtres
dans le bâtiment principal.
Elle est constituée de viande de volaille, de
poisson accompagnée de pain,
De fruits, de miel et servie avec
du lait, de la bière ou du vin.
À en croire la littérature
et les dessins parvenus jusqu'à nous,
Toutes les classes sociales privilégiaient
une heureuse vie de famille.
Le pharaon était autorisé à
entretenir plusieurs femmes,
Mais la plupart des Égyptiens
étaient monogames.
Les enfants avaient leurs jouets.
Des hochets, des poupées articulées
et des animaux familiers.
Des chats, par ailleurs
considérés comme sacrés.
Des chiens,
Et même des babouins.
Quant aux adultes, ils pratiquaient, pour se
distraire, le senet, un jeu sur damier,
Ainsi qu'une sorte de jeu de dés.
La musique était très appréciée
des anciens Égyptiens.
Ils ont joué sur des instruments
comparables à la harpe,
À la flûte et à la clarinette.
Parmi leurs autres distractions, des
spectacles de danse, de lutte ou de magie,
sans oublier, pour les hommes,
les parties de pêche, de tenderie,
Et de chasse au crocodile
ou à l'hippopotame.
L'éducation était considérée
comme essentielle.
Les enfants apprenaient l'écriture,
l'arithmétique et la géométrie,
Dans l'espoir de faire carrière
dans la haute administration.
L'ambition suprême.
On connaît surtout des anciens Égyptiens,
leurs chefs d'œuvre architecturaux.
Mais ils étaient aussi brillants en
matière de sciences et de littérature.
Ils nous ont légué une somme considérable
de chansons, de poèmes, de chroniques,
De romans et de récits d'aventures.
L'un de ces derniers,
qui a traversé les âges,
Inlassablement raconté aux enfants,
Décrit les aventures passionnantes
de Sinbad, le marin.
L'eau, qui exerçait sur eux
une grande fascination,
En fit des experts en constructions navales.
C'est un talent qui,
comme celui de leurs architectes,
Suppose une excellente connaissance des
problèmes d'arithmétique ou de géométrie.
Quant à leurs ingénieurs, outre leur
aptitude à faire jaillir de terre,
Quelques uns des monuments les plus
gigantesques jamais imaginés par l'homme,
Ils nous ont légué aussi une technique
dont nous tirons encore des leçons,
Celle de l'irrigation.
Les crues du Nil, qui peuvent
tripler le débit du fleuve,
Ont toujours tenu l'Égypte sous leur loi.
On pourrait écrire l'histoire de cette
région avec pour seul fil conducteur,
la politique d'irrigation
menée par ses princes.
Elle débute avec la construction d'un
réseau de canaux dans le Fayoum,
Une vaste dépression au sud de Memphis,
Dès le début du deuxième
millénaire avant Jésus-Christ.
L'observation du cycle inondations,
germination, récoltes,
Inspira aussi aux Égyptiens la nécessité
de mettre au point un calendrier.
Pour point de départ, il choisirent
le lever de l'étoile Sirius,
Dont ils avaient constaté qu'elle apparaissait
régulièrement à une latitude déterminée.
Entre chaque apparition de Sirius,
dans cette position céleste,
Ils comptèrent 365 apparitions du Soleil,
correspondant à ce qui
constitue aujourd'hui encore,
Les 365 jours de notre calendrier.
Ils divisèrent également les journées
en 24h et créèrent le cadran solaire.
Enfin, pour compléter cette maîtrise
du temps, ils inventèrent l'horloge,
Afin de déterminer
plus précisément encore,
Le défilement des heures en faisant s'écouler
de l'eau dans une vasque par un trou,
Au diamètre soigneusement étudié.
Grande aussi était la réputation
de la médecine égyptienne.
Plusieurs papyrus parvenus jusqu'à
nous justifient cette renommée.
Une série d'entre eux,
divisés en 877 chapitres,
Concernent le diagnostic et la manière
de guérir des malades,
Qui concernent pratiquement
toutes les parties du corps.
Un autre papyrus codifie le traitement
chirurgical des blessures.
Un autre encore qui serait dû à Imhotep
et remonterait donc à l'ancien Empire,
traite des troubles cardiaques.
Les maladies du cœur, considérées
aujourd'hui comme des fléaux modernes,
Sévissaient donc déjà dans l'Antiquité.
Les 19ᵉ et 20ᵉ dynasties virent se
succéder, entre autres,
Onze pharaons qui régnèrent
sous le nom de Ramsès.
Pour baptiser dès lors,
l'âge des ramessides,
Cette période, qui couvre pour
l'essentiel les 13ᵉ et 12ᵉ siècles,
Marque l'apogée du Nouvel Empire.
Avant qu'il soit miné par
des incursions étrangères.
Comme au temps des grandes pyramides
de L'ancien Empire,
Ce fut une époque de travaux prestigieux.
De la Nubie au delta, Ramsès II
et Ramsès III offrirent à l'Égypte,
Des œuvres d'une qualité nouvelle.
Jamais après eux ne fût atteint
un tel niveau de perfection,
Celui des temples de Louxor et de Karnak.
Une accumulation de constructions cyclopéen,
Peuplée d'effigies énigmatiques
ou presque familières,
Comme ce scarabée de granit considéré
par les Égyptiens comme symbole d'espoir.
La salle hypostyle du grand
sanctuaire d'Amon à Karnak,
comme les colonnades du temple de Louxor,
Figure parmi les réalisations les plus
impressionnantes de l'architecture,
Non seulement égyptienne mais mondiale.
Leur construction s'étale sur
une période de quelque 200 ans,
Comme en témoignent les reproductions
de scènes rituelles,
Et les hiéroglyphes qui y
sont gravés par centaines.
Les temples de Karnak et de Louxor,
Sont l'œuvre essentiellement
de deux grands pharaons.
Aménophis III et Ramsès II.
Pour fêter l'année nouvelle située
par les Égyptiens au cœur de l'été,
Des processions somptueuses déambulaient
d'un temple à l'autre.
Le temple d'Abou Simbel fut également
érigé sur l'ordre de Ramsès II.
Quatre statues monolithes du Grand pharaon
continuent d'en garder l'entrée.
L'une d'elles est brisée à hauteur des genoux.
Les socles qui les soutiennent
sont couverts de hiéroglyphes,
Qui exaltent la gloire du souverain.
Ils portent d'autres statues
de taille plus modeste,
Qui représentent des membres
de la famille royale.
L'ensemble mesure plus
de 20 mètres de haut.
Les proportions sont parfaites.
La proximité immédiate du Nil ne permettait
pourtant pas de prendre un recul suffisant,
pour les vérifier.
À proximité, Ramsès deux fit tailler
dans la falaise un second temple plus modeste.
Il le dédia à Hathor, déesse
de la joie et de l'amour,
À laquelle il fit donner par une délicate
attention les traits de son épouse Néfertari.
Ici encore, des effigies monumentales du
couple royal décorent l'entrée du sanctuaire.
De tous les pharaons bâtisseurs,
Ramsès II fut le plus prolifique,
Peut-être parce que ce géant,
réputé pour sa robustesse,
Mourut nonagénaire à une époque où
l'espérance de vie n'atteignait pas 40 ans.
Sa momie aussi nous apprend qu'il
était d'une taille supérieure,
À celle de la moyenne des Égyptiens.
C'est le signe de la vie qui accueille
le visiteur au seuil d'Abou Simbel.
Dans la première salle, huit piliers
osiriaques, dont les colosses,
Aux traits de Ramsès II supportent
un plafond orné de vautours.
Osiris, dieu bien aimé des hommes,
aurait été tué par un frère jaloux,
Ramené à la vie par l'amour
de son épouse, Isis,
Et désigné pour régner sur un au-delà
qui, pour les Égyptiens,
Était le foyer de toutes
les forces créatrices,
De la fécondité, de la nature
et de la vie elle-même.
Ramsès II pris au pied de la lettre la
tradition qui attribuait au pharaon,
Une essence divine.
Sur son ordre, ses architectes firent en
sorte qu'au jour anniversaire de sa naissance,
Et à celui de son couronnement,
Le soleil illumine complètement
l'intérieur du temple,
Afin que chacun puisse les voir, lui
et ses frères les dieux, assis côte à côte.
En 1963, les temples d'Abou Simbel furent
menacés par les projets de construction,
Du barrage d'Assouan.
Ils furent sauvés grâce à
une campagne menée par l'Unesco.
Découpé en un millier de blocs
d'une trentaine de tonnes,
Ils furent transportés quelque
180 mètres en retrait,
Et 64 mètres plus haut.
Puis remontés à l'identique.
Ces travaux durèrent près de dix ans,
Et demeurent le plus brillant témoignage
de ce que la solidarité internationale,
Peut réaliser dans le domaine culturel.
Les ingénieurs contemporains mirent un tel
soin à respecter l'orientation des monuments,
Que deux fois par an, avec cependant
un tout petit jour de décalage,
Le Soleil continue de célébrer
les anniversaires de Ramsès II,
En,illuminant l'intérieur de l'édifice.
Ultérieurement, un autre temple situé à
proximité, celui de Philae,
A également fait l'objet d'une opération
de sauvetage patronnée par l'Unesco.
Dédié à Isis,
Il fut construit au IVᵉ siècle avant
Jésus-Christ par les derniers pharaons,
Sous la 30ᵉ dynastie.
Terminé par les Romains,
Il demeura ouvert au culte jusqu'au
milieu du Vᵉ siècle après Jésus-Christ.
Mais revenons à la vallée des rois et aux plus
illustres souverains des 19ᵉ et 20ᵉ dynasties.
Le temple funéraire de Ramsès II, le Ramesseum,
Fut dédié au dieu Amon.
Dans le sanctuaire, l'un des plus beaux dans
l'Antiquité mais aujourd'hui très endommagé,
gît une statue monumentale du pharaon.
Ce colosse d'un poids de 1000
tonnes fut renversé, dit on,
Sur l'ordre du roi perse Cambyse, conquérant
de l'Égypte au VIᵉ siècle avant Jésus-Christ.
Une statue de granit noir
et des décorations murales,
Restituent tout le classicisme
du Nouvel Empire.
À un kilomètre de là s'élève
le temple de Médinet Habou.
Une sorte de copie du Ramesseum,
Que Ramsès III fit construire 150 ans
plus tard pour son propre usage.
Contrairement à son modèle, c'est l'un des
temples d'Égypte qui a le mieux résisté au temps.
Ramsès III fut le dernier grand pharaon.
Dès sa mort, l'Empire subit une décadence qui
s'accéléra sous le règne de ses huit successeurs.
L'extinction de la 20ᵉ dynastie en 1085,
inspira de nouvelles convoitises.
D'abord assumé par des
pharaons issus du delta,
Le pouvoir fut confisqué par
des Libyens, puis par des Nubiens,
Qui restaurèrent pour un siècle,
une paix relative.
Mais de nouveaux envahisseurs
se pressaient aux frontières.
À l'ouest, une nouvelle fois, les Libyens.
À l'est, les Assyriens
et surtout les Perses de Cambyse,
Fils de Cyrus, qui s'emparèrent finalement
de l'Égypte en 525 avant Jésus-Christ.
Ils la gouvernèrent durant 200 ans.
C'est à cette époque que
l'historien grec Hérodote,
Visita le pays et traça
de la société égyptienne,
Un portrait qui fit autorité pendant des siècles.
En 333 avant Jésus Christ, c'est
Alexandre le Grand qui conquit le pays,
À la tête de ses phalanges macédoniennes.
Il créa une nouvelle capitale
baptisée de son nom Alexandrie.
Bientôt peuplée de 300 000 habitants et
destinée à devenir le plus grand port,
Et l'un des foyers de culture
de la Méditerranée orientale.
Lorsqu'il mourut, dix ans plus tard,
Le pouvoir passa à un
de ses généraux, Ptolémée.
Qui s'érigea en pharaon,
fondateur d'une nouvelle dynastie.
Curieuse fusion d'une civilisation
terrienne plusieurs fois millénaire,
Et d'une civilisation de marins,
Vieille seulement de quelques siècles.
Une expérience d'ailleurs très vite
compromise par la puissance romaine.
Les Ptolémées s'étaient à ce point
endettés à l'égard de Rome,
Qu'ils n'eurent plus comme
solution de remboursement,
Que de céder leur empire à leurs créditeurs.
Tandis que le pharaon se rendait
à Rome pour concrétiser cette cession,
Sa fille ainée tenta de s'emparer du trône.
Mal lui en prît.
Elle fut aussitôt assassinée
par des fidèles de son père.
Sa sœur Bérénice eut le tort de
vouloir usurper à son tour le pouvoir.
Revenu en hâte au pays avec le support des
Romains, le pharaon la fit exécuter.
À sa mort, l'égypte passa à
deux autre de ses enfants,
Ptolémée XII et Cléopâtre VII,
âgés respectivement de 10 et 18 ans.
Ses passions et son suicide ont fait à
Cléopâtre une part belle dans l'histoire,
Mais sa réputation doit beaucoup, sans doute,
à la légende et à l'imagination.
Sa libertinage ne constituait peut être qu'une
astucieuse méthode pour se maintenir,
Sur un trône d'Égypte
alors bien chancelant.
Consciente de ne pouvoir s'imposer
sans l'appui de Rome,
Elle réussit à séduire Jules César
et à lui faire oublier,
Jusqu'à l'existence de l'énorme dette
financière de l'Égypte à l'égard de Rome.
Elle subjugua ensuite Antoine,
l'un des triumvirs successeurs de César.
Mais ce fût pour leur malheur.
Octave, principal rival d'Antoine,
Ne put en effet supporter que celui-ci
prétende imposer les enfants naturels,
Qu'il avait eus de Cléopâtre comme
héritier de l'Empire romain.
À ce niveau de confusion,
Il ne restait aux adversaires
qu'à en découdre.
En l'an 31 avant Jésus Christ à Actium,
sur la côte grecque,
Antoine et Cléopâtre subirent,
des œuvres de leur ennemi Octave,
Une défaite sanglante et définitive.
Encerclée, leur flotte
fut contrainte de capituler.
Antoine et Cléopâtre échappèrent
à leur adversaire,
Mais l'un et l'autre se suicidèrent
peu de temps après.
Octave prit alors le nom de César Auguste
et régna sans partage sur l'Empire romain,
Y compris l'Égypte.
Et il décréta que pour célébrer
la défaite de Cléopâtre,
Le sixième mois du calendrier romain
s'appellerait désormais le mois d'Auguste,
Devenu aujourd'hui le mois d'août.
Décidément rancunier, Octave fut pour
beaucoup dans la réputation de débauchée,
faite par L'histoire à Cléopâtre.
L'égypte fut gouvernée pendant sept siècles
par les Romains, puis, après la scission,
de l'Empire en 395 de notre ère,
par leurs héritiers,
Les Byzantins chrétiens de Constantinople.
Selon la tradition, c'est Saint Marc
l'évangéliste qui, le premier,
Prêcha la foi chrétienne
dans la région du delta.
Et c'est en l'an 40 que
fut bâtie, à Alexandrie,
La première église d'Égypte.
Très vite, cependant, les nouveaux chrétiens
furent divisés par des différends théologiques.
Au concile de Chalcédoine en 451,
Les évêques décidèrent de privilégier la nature
humaine de Jésus par rapport à sa nature divine.
En désaccord avec cette position,
les chrétiens égyptiens, les coptes,
Entrèrent ouvertement en désaccord
avec le patriarche de Constantinople.
Les coptes considéraient leurs
ancêtres comme des païens.
Ils s'efforcèrent de rompre
avec leur passé pharaonique,
En en détruisant notamment quelques
précieux témoignages artistiques.
Leur haine religieuse
et politique contre Byzance,
Allait d'ailleurs les pousser très vite
à rompre aussi avec leur présent.
En 639, lorsqu'ils envahirent l'Égypte,
Les Arabes furent accueillis
par les Coptes en libérateur.
Moyennant quoi les chrétiens, minoritaires
mais qui constituaient alors,
comme aujourd'hui plus
de 10% de la population,
Furent autorisés à demeurer sur
place en citoyens à part entière.
Les Égyptiens vont vivre ainsi
pendant plus de 300 ans,
Sous l'autorité des califes
de Damas puis de Bagdad,
Soumis aux lois coraniques mais
bénéficiant d'une large autonomie.
Entre temps, les Arabes se sont
divisés à leur tour en factions rivales.
En 969, les Fatimides originaires de Tripoli,
Envahissent l'Égypte et l'arrachent
aux califes de Bagdad.
Leur chef établit sa capitale dans
une petite cité du sud du delta.
Ils la baptisent el-Qahéra,
la Victorieuse.
C'est aujourd'hui, Le Caire.
En quelques années, les Fatimides
font de l'Égypte un pays riche.
La plaque tournante du commerce
entre l'Orient et l'Occident.
Le cœur d'un vaste empire qui couvre
l'Afrique du Nord et la Palestine,
La Sicile, la Syrie et l'Arabie.
Ils tentent ensuite de supplanter définitivement
les sunnites qui règnent à Bagdad.
Ils comptent notamment sur leur
position géographique idéale,
Entre l'Europe et l'Inde.
Chacune de leurs innombrables
caravanes marchandes,
Héberge des propagandistes religieux
qui vont porter la parole de l'islam,
De l'Espagne à l'océan Indien.
Par contre, rien ne semble pouvoir les
réconcilier avec leurs frères ennemis de Bagdad.
Même pas la menace que fait peser sur les
uns et les autres les premières croisades.
Il faudra un demi siècle pour
que l'émir d'Alep, Nûreddîn,
Réussisse à organiser la jihad,
la guerre sainte contre l'envahisseur.
En 1171, les troubles de Nûreddîn
s'emparent de l'Égypte,
Avec à leur tête l'illustre Saladin.
Trois ans plus tard, à la mort de son maître,
Saladin se proclame sultan.
En 1187, Saladin s'empare de Jérusalem,
Et reconquiert en quelques mois la
quasi totalité des territoires occupés,
Par les Francs depuis 1097.
Cette victoire suscita
une troisième croisade,
Elle même suivie de plusieurs autres
qui s'échelonnèrent sur un siècle.
Plusieurs prirent pour cible l'Égypte,
considérée comme un des plus
solides bastions de l'islam.
Aucune ne réussit à l'ébranler vraiment.
Entre temps, en 1251,
La dynastie de Saladin avait été renversée
par une sorte de coup d'État militaire.
Les sultans avaient recruté des mercenaires
musulmans originaires de Turquie,
Les Mamelouks, moitié mongols,
moitié slaves.
Soumis à une hiérarchie
militaire très stricte,
Lassées d'obéir aux ordres
de leur maître indolent,
Les Mamelouks prirent le pouvoir.
Ils confisquèrent les terres et les
redistribuèrent suivant un système féodal.
Chaque nouveau propriétaire était tenu de
verser à l'armée deux tiers de sa production.
Ce régime militaire qui alliait
curieusement cruauté et raffinement,
Fut ébranlé au début du XVᵉ siècle
par des invasions mongoles,
Qui dévastèrent Damas
et tout le nord du sultanat.
Vint ensuite une longue période
d'épidémies et de calamités naturelles.
Enfin, le sultan prit la décision
catastrophique de faire main basse,
Sur toutes les marchandises qui
transitaient dans ses ports.
Cette mesure insolite
poussa irrésistiblement,
Les Européens à explorer
une nouvelle voie commerciale,
Qui leur permettent d'atteindre l'Orient
sans être soumis à une escale égyptienne.
Lorsqu'en 1499, Vasco de Gama
annonça sa découverte,
Une nouvelle route des Indes via
le Cap de Bonne Espérance,
La puissance économique
de l'Égypte avait vécu.
De plus, la puissante flotte portugaise
pourchassa par représaille,
Tout bateau égyptien surpris à
naviguer dans l'océan Indien.
Les Mamelouks avaient donc fait leur temps.
En 1517, ils furent balayés
par les Turcs ottomans.
Le pire était à venir.
Pendant près de trois siècles, les pachas
turcs installaient dans la citadelle du Caire,
n'exercèrent sur la province conquise
qu'une surveillance administrative.
Il s'agissait pour eux
de percevoir des taxes.
Pour le reste, la conquête ottomane arrêta net
la prospérité matérielle et artistique du pays.
Très vite, les Mamelouks vaincus
avaient redressé la tête.
C'est parmi eux que les Turcs
recrutaient les percepteurs d'impôts,
Qui devinrent bientôt les véritables
maîtres du pays.
Grâce à un florissant commerce d'esclaves
capturés au Proche-Orient et en Afrique.
Les Mamelouks profitèrent aussi
du fait que les Turcs,
Consacraient l'essentiel de leur temps aux
guerres qui les opposait à la Grèce et à la Russie.
Lorsqu'il investit l'Égypte en 1798,
Bonaparte fit diffuser une proclamation
dans laquelle il affirmait qu'il n'était là.
Que pour débarrasser
l'Égypte de la tyrannie ottomane.
Mais lorsqu'il débarqua,
Quelques heures seulement après
le départ de l'amiral anglais Nelson,
C'est aux mamelouks qu'il se trouva confronté.
Les défenseurs n'hésitèrent pas
à brûler leurs propres flottilles,
Pour tenter de ralentir
la progression des Français.
Peine perdue, les troupes de Bonaparte
progressant à marche forcée,
Rejoignirent bientôt leurs adversaires
à l'ombre des pyramides de Gizeh.
Habile stratège, Bonaparte se garde bien de
se précipiter sur la terrible cavalerie turque.
Il forma ses fantassins en carrés
flanqués d'artillerie sur lesquels,
Vagues par vagues, les Mamelouks
s'obstinèrent à charger.
Jusqu'à se faire impitoyablement massacrer.
Les combats se prolongèrent
durant une journée entière.
Le lendemain, Bonaparte était maître du pays.
L'expédition française se solda par un
relatif fiasco diplomatique et militaire.
Mais les savants et les artistes qui
accompagnaient Bonaparte dans sa campagne,
furent ensuite rappelés au monde,
l'existence d'une fabuleuse civilisation,
Alors tombée dans l'oubli.
Et cette présence européenne en Égypte,
Contribua à rétablir les liens
entre l'Occident et l'Orient.
Cette occupation dura trois ans.
Déjà vainqueur de la flotte
d'invasion à Aboukir,
les Anglais ne désarmaient pas.
En 1801, alliés aux Turcs, ils chassèrent
définitivement le corps expéditionnaire français.
Livrés à eux mêmes, les Égyptiens, peu habitués
à prendre leurs responsabilités politiques,
Et soumis aux caprices de potentats locaux,
Semblaient à nouveau mûrs pour l'anarchie
lorsqu'un ancien officier de l'armée ottomane,
d'origine albanaise, prit le pouvoir.
Méhémet Ali, rétablit l'ordre.
Se fit reconnaître vice roi héréditaire
d'Égypte par le sultan de Constantinople,
son vassal en titre.
Et régna 45 ans sous la protection de son
vassal de fait, le gouvernement de Londres,
Très soucieux de garder ouverte
la porte de l'Orient.
Les Anglais avaient décelé en lui
un allié particulièrement énergique.
Après avoir utilisé les Mamelouks pour se
débarrasser des factions activistes arabes,
il invita leurs principaux chefs à un
banquet et les fit mettre à mort,
Sans autre forme de procès.
S'il était despotique, Méhémet Ali
était aussi un homme de progrès.
Il s'entoura de conseillers étrangers
qui aidèrent à moderniser son pays.
À former sur place des administrateurs
et des enseignants,
Des médecins et des ingénieurs, à
développer de nouvelles formes de culture,
À créer des industries.
En quelques années, il arrache à l'Égypte,
à ses mœurs moyenâgeuses,
Et lui donna une dimension internationale.
Il créa une armée organisée à l'européenne,
forte de 100 000 hommes.
L'une des plus puissantes de la région.
Devenu octogénaire, Méhémet Ali décida
de céder le pouvoir à son fils Ibrahim,
Qui, depuis un certain temps déjà,
dirigeait de fait le gouvernement.
Mais Ibrahim mourut très
rapidement d'une tuberculose,
Contractée au cours d'une expédition
militaire en Anatolie.
C'est alors son propre fils,
Abbas, qui se trouva amené,
à assurer la vice royauté.
Considéré comme la brebis
galeuse de la famille,
Abbas commença par régler ses comptes
en épurant impitoyablement son entourage.
Très méfiants à l'égard des Occidentaux,
Il expulsa beaucoup de conseillers
européens recrutés par son grand-père.
Après cinq ans d'un règne déplorable,
Il fut assassiné par sa garde personnelle.
C'est alors un autre fils
de Méhémet Ali, Saïd,
Qui, en 1854, hérita du trône.
Élevé en Europe, il restaura aussitôt
la politique d'occidentalisation du pays.
Enfant, Saïd avait tendance
à prendre de l'embonpoint.
Pour lui conserver sa ligne, son grand-père
le soumettait à des exercices physiques,
Et à un régime très strict.
Lorsqu'il réussissait à s'échapper, il se
réfugiait au consulat de France au Caire,
Où il s'était lié d'amitié avec un diplomate,
Ferdinand de Lesseps,
Qui le gavait de macaronis.
Arrivé au pouvoir, Saïd rappela
aussitôt son ami,
Qui avait été expulsé
quelque temps auparavant.
Et c'est de Lesseps qui lui proposa
de creuser à travers l'isthme de Suez,
Un canal qui, pour les Européens, raccourcirait
de 7000 kilomètres la route des Indes.
Malgré la réticence
du gouvernement britannique,
De Lesseps obtint la concession
des travaux qui débutèrent en 1859.
Faute de capitaux,
Les promoteurs du projet n'avaient
pu acheter qu'un matériel très insuffisant.
Pour réaliser cet ouvrage gigantesque,
Il fallut recourir à des procédés
littéralement pharaoniques.
Recruter 20 000 ouvriers, appelés à travailler
dans des conditions extrêmement dures.
Beaucoup moururent de malnutrition,
de maladie ou d'épuisement.
La construction du canal dura dix ans.
Saïd n'assista pas à son
inauguration en 1869.
Il était mort depuis six ans déjà,
à peine quadragénaire.
Outre le canal, il avait apporté
à son peuple les chemins de fer,
L'eau courante, l'éclairage au gaz.
Des écoles et des usines.
Mais ses efforts de modernisation
avaient coûté fort cher.
Pour la première fois de son histoire,
la fertilité de l'Égypte,
Ne suffisait plus à couvrir ses dépenses.
En 1863, lorsque Ismaïl succéda à Saïd,
Il s'engagea à ne pas alourdir la dette.
La guerre civile qui faisait
rage aux États-Unis,
Lui permit de vendre le coton
égyptien au prix fort.
Il consacra cet argent à
de nouveaux grands travaux,
Mais aussi à des investissements culturels.
Ainsi, en même temps qu'il faisait construire
des ports, des canaux, des voies ferrées,
Et qu'il faisait terminer
l'aménagement du canal,
Ouvert en grande pompe en présence d'un
prestigieux parterre de personnalités européennes,
Il décida, afin de célébrer
ce dernier événement,
De faire construire un opéra où fut créée Aïda,
spécialement commandée
à Verdi pour la circonstance.
Ismaïl, s'efforça aussi
d'affermir sa dynastie.
Modifiant la Constitution,
il se fit proclamer khédive,
Et s'arrogea le droit de léguer le trône
à ses enfants par ordre de primogéniture,
Suivant l'usage appliqué
dans les royaumes européens.
Mais entre temps, la guerre civile
américaine avait pris fin,
Les prix du coton s'effondrèrent
et la dette extérieure monta en flèche.
Pour l'apurer, le khédive fut obligé en 1875,
De vendre les parts égyptiennes
du canal de Suez aux Britanniques.
Malgré cela, le pays
courait à la banqueroute.
Il finit par tomber totalement sous la coupe
financière de la France et de l'Angleterre.
Et cette dernière allait bientôt
rester maître du terrain,
En prenant prétexte de manifestations,
puis d'une véritable révolte suscitée en 1879,
Par son interventionnisme.
Les Britanniques écrasèrent les insurgés.
Ils exercèrent un pouvoir de fait par
l'intermédiaire du fils d'Ismaïl, Tawfiq.
Et ils rachetèrent le Sinaï à l'Égypte,
Pour créer une zone tampon à l'est du canal.
Pendant plus de 60 ans, la situation
internationale dissuadera la Grande-Bretagne,
De lever cette tutelle.
Elle va même la renforcer durant
les deux guerres mondiales,
Afin de disposer en Égypte
d'une solide base d'opération.
C'est à elle, que le général anglais Montgomery,
en arrêtant les blindés du maréchal Rommel,
Infligea aux Allemands en 1942, leur première
grande défaite terrestre de la guerre.
Au lendemain de la victoire alliée,
L'Égypte trouva dans le monde arabe l'appui
nécessaire pour accéder enfin à l'indépendance.
En 1947, les troupes britanniques
se replièrent sur la zone du canal.
Dans le même temps, dépassés
par l'ampleur de l'immigration,
Et de la résistance armée
des Juifs de Palestine,
Londres soutint la création
d'un État d'Israël.
Les pays arabes les plus proches
du nouvel État hébreu,
Concluent alors, à l'initiative de
l'Égypte, un pacte militaire.
Celui-ci engage l'Arabie saoudite,
L'irak,
La Jordanie,
La Syrie.
Le Liban,
Et le Yémen.
Les régimes signataires méditent une
reconquête militaire de la Palestine.
Ils espèrent une victoire facile.
En fait, ils subissent une humiliante défaite.
La plupart d'entre eux vont
d'ailleurs sombrer dans ce naufrage,
Et notamment celui du roi d'Égypte, Farouk.
Une société secrète de jeunes
officiers contestataires,
Baptisée Comité des officiers libres,
mène une agitation souterraine.
Les comploteurs prévoient de s'emparer du
pouvoir suprême dans le courant de l'année 54.
Mais des troubles qui opposent les Égyptiens
aux soldats britanniques dans la zone de Suez,
et le déclenchement au Caire
d'émeutes anti-occidentales,
Incite les putschistes à avancer
la date de leur prise de pouvoir.
Le 22 juillet 1952,
Le bruit se répand que le roi serait en train
de se constituer une garde prétorienne.
Dans la nuit, les officiers libres,
Dirigés par le lieutenant colonel
Gamal Abdel Nasser,
Passent à l'action et s'emparent des points
stratégiques de la capitale.
Le roi Farouk ne trouve aucun allié
capable de sauver son trône.
Il accepte d'abdiquer.
Les putschistes confient d'abord le gouvernement
à des politiciens de l'ancien régime,
Mais cela cède à leurs vieux démons.
Ils pratiquent l'intrigue
plutôt que la réconciliation.
Nasser dira plus tard :
"À l'époque, si quelqu'un m'avait demandé
ce que je souhaitais par dessus tout,
J'aurais dit que c'était d'entendre un
Égyptien parler loyalement d'un autre Égyptien,
Avoir le sentiment que les Égyptiens
avaient ouvert leur cœur,
Au pardon et à l'amour
pour leurs frères égyptiens.
Trouver enfin un Égyptien qui ne
consacre pas tout son temps,
À attaquer le point de vue
d'un autre Égyptien."
Les officiers libres décident donc
d'assumer eux mêmes le pouvoir.
En 1953, ils proclament la République.
Nasser est extrêmement populaire.
Pour ses compatriotes, il est celui qui
a mis fin aux 2500 ans de domination étrangère.
Bientôt, sa popularité s'étend
à l'ensemble du monde arabe,
Et même du tiers monde, dont il
devient le grand leader charismatique.
En politique intérieure,
le premier objectif de Nasser,
Est de supprimer la mainmise des grands
propriétaires terriens sur l'économie.
D'effacer toute forme
d'influence britannique,
Et surtout d'améliorer sensiblement
le niveau de vie du peuple égyptien.
Sa politique étrangère vise à créer une
forme spécifique de socialisme panarabe.
À se poser en porte parole
des pays non-alignés,
Et à battre en brèche l'interventionnisme
britannique au Proche et Moyen Orient.
Boudé par les États-Unis,
il se tourne vers l'U.R.S.S.
Et les pays du bloc soviétique qui lui fournissent
une assistance industrielle considérable,
Et une profusion d'armes,
de chars et d'avions.
Devant les réticences de la Banque mondiale,
de Londres et de Washington,
À financer le barrage d'Assouan,
le 26 juillet 1956,
Nasser nationalise la Compagnie
du canal de Suez.
C'est le début d'une crise sans précédent,
accrue par une tension croissante,
Aux frontières israélo arabes.
Le 29 octobre,
les Israéliens passent à l'attaque.
Deux jours plus tard, la France et la
Grande-Bretagne interviennent militairement.
Il faudra une énergique intervention
américano soviétique,
Pour étouffer le conflit.
Nasser est le grand vainqueur
moral de l'opération.
C'est à lui que les égyptiens, leurs alliés
arabes et tous les pays non-alignés,
attribuent le mérite
d'avoir stoppé l'agression.
Peu après, Nasser est accueilli à bras
ouverts par les maîtres du Kremlin.
Qui se font un plaisir de financer la
construction du barrage d'Assouan,
Moyennant bien entendu un renforcement
des influences soviétiques en Égypte.
En 1958, Nasser réussit à persuader
les Syriens de se fédérer avec l'Égypte,
Au sein d'une République arabe unie.
Mais dès 1961, le partenaire
syrien fait sécession.
Populaire auprès de la majorité
de ses compatriotes,
Le président n'en est pas moins
impitoyable avec ses opposants.
Et en politique étrangère,
il n'enregistre pas que des succès.
Ces harcèlements à l'égard
d'Israël conduisent en 67,
À une nouvelle guerre
entre Juifs et Arabes.
Qui, pour ces derniers, tourne au désastre.
Ils y perdent le Sinaï, Gaza,
la Cisjordanie et les hauteurs du Golan.
Nasser n'en conservera pas moins,
jusqu'à sa mort en 1970,
Leur estime et leur soutien.
Nasser a lui même désigné comme successeur
un autre ancien officier libre,
Le vice président Anouar el-Sadate.
Très vite, celui-ci prend ses
distances vis à vis de l'URSS.
En 1972, il expulse
ses conseillers soviétiques.
L'année suivante, il lance son armée
entièrement réorganisée à l'assaut d'Israël.
Cette fois, les Égyptiens se mesurent
efficacement à leurs adversaires.
Au point que Sadate se trouve
en position de négocier,
Sous la bénédiction des États-Unis,
des accords équitables avec Tel-Aviv.
L'égypte récupère notamment certaines zones
du canal et une partie du Sinaï,
Occupée par les Israéliens.
Novembre 1977, à Jérusalem, c'est la
réunion historique de la paix retrouvée,
Entre le président égyptien et le
Premier ministre israélien Begin.
Cette poignée de main aura aussi pour
conséquence de valoir à Anouar el-Sadate,
La confiance de la très méfiante
diplomatie américaine.
Par contre, la paix signée avec
l'ennemi israélien,
A attiré au président égyptien quelques
solides rancunes chez ses alliés naturels.
En passant de la stratégie de l'affrontement
à celle de la négociation,
Sadate a inauguré un style politique nouveau,
qui inquiète ses alliés arabes,
peu habitués sous Nasser,
À un discours aussi conciliant.
Un an après la visite de Sadate en Israël,
Le président Jimmy Carter le convie,
ainsi que Menahem Begin,
À Camp David, aux États-Unis.
Ces entretiens tripartites aboutiront
à un accord global.
Cadre d'un règlement pacifique
du conflit du Proche-Orient,
Et d'un véritable traité de paix
entre l'Égypte et l'Israël.
La signature de ce document ne marque
que le commencement de la paix.
Mais ce commencement était indispensable.
Assez de souffrances,
assez de mises en demeure,
Assez de désespoir,
Assez de découragement.
Assez de mères qui pleurent
la mort d'un enfant.
Assez de jeunes gens tués pour un
conflit qui ne profite à personne.
Assez de guerre et assez de sang versé
entre Arabes et Israéliens.
Le traité de paix élaboré à Camp David est
définitivement ratifié le 26 mars 1979,
mettait fin à 30 ans de guerre.
Les négociateurs n'aboutiront cependant à
aucune décision concernant l'épineux problème,
de l'occupation par les Israéliens des
territoires de Cisjordanie et de Gaza.
Palestiniens et Jordaniens refusèrent de
participer aux négociations.
L'égypte, Israël et les États-Unis,
Tentèrent d'arriver seuls à
l'élaboration d'une solution négociée.
Ils ne réussirent cependant pas
à aplanir leurs différends.
Les discussions furent suspendues en 1982
sans que le problème soit résolu.
Pour arriver à réaliser ces
ambitieux projets de développement,
Anouar el-Sadate relâche le contrôle très sévère
de l'Etat sur tous les circuits économiques,
Et fait appel aux investisseurs
privés étrangers.
Il s'efforce d'effacer l'image de régime
fort qui était celle de l'Égypte sous Nasser.
Il allège l'appareil policier et
fait même passer en jugement,
D'anciens fonctionnaires soupçonnés
d'atteintes aux droits de l'homme,
Dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions officielles.
Il fait scrupuleusement respecté
dans les tribunaux les droits de la défense,
Et abolit toute forme de torture.
Enfin, il s'efforce, mais en vain, d'étendre
la participation populaire au processus politique.
Cette politique libérale suscite la colère
des extrémistes nationalistes et religieux.
Le 6 octobre 1981, au cours du
défilé militaire de la fête nationale,
Le président Anouar el-Sadate est assassiné
par des musulmans fanatiques.
Hosni Moubarak, ancien chef des forces
aériennes et vice président depuis 1975,
Accéda au pouvoir.
Il sera réélu à deux reprises.
Sans renier l'accord de Camp David
signé par son prédécesseur,
Il réussit au fil des années à s'imposer
comme l'un des leaders du monde arabe.
Cette réhabilitation se concrétisa
lors de la réintégration de l'Égypte,
Dans la Ligue arabe en 1989.
Sur le plan international
dans l'enceinte de l'ONU,
Ou à la tribune de l'Organisation
de l'unité africaine,
Dont l'Egypte assuma la Présidence
à la fin des années 80,
Sa voix fit autorité.
À l'intérieur de ses frontières,
le président et son parti,
Le Parti national démocrate,
au pouvoir depuis 1978,
Semblent bénéficier d'un large
soutien populaire.
Moubarak a cependant ouvert le processus
politique à l'opposition qui,
Aux élections législatives de 1987,
A remporté une centaine
des 454 sièges à pourvoir.
Restent les dures réalités économiques qui
menacent traditionnellement,
La stabilité du pouvoir.
La Constitution confère l'autorité
suprême du pays au président,
Élu par référendum et pour six ans,
Et qui désigne son vice président, son
Premier ministre et les membres du cabinet.
Le pouvoir législatif est assumé
par l'Assemblée ou Conseil du peuple,
Composé de 454 membres élus
et dix désignés par le président.
50% des sièges sont réservés à
des ouvriers ou à des agriculteurs.
Le mandat de ces parlementaires
est d'une durée de cinq ans.
Il existe également un conseil consultatif
composé de 70 membres choisis par le président,
Et 140 élus.
Mais ses pouvoirs sont limités.
De puissantes instances régionales
gèrent les affaires locales.
Elles sont composées
de gouverneurs et de maires,
Nommés par le gouvernement
ou élus par la population.
Si l'essentiel du pouvoir est concentré au niveau
du président et de son Parti national démocrate,
Majoritaire au sein
de l'Assemblée du peuple,
Les autres formations politiques ont
la possibilité de mener sur le terrain,
Une véritable stratégie d'opposition.
Elles sont au nombre de cinq.
Le Rassemblement unioniste progressiste.
Le Parti libéral socialiste.
Le parti humain,
Le Parti socialiste travailliste
et le nouveau parti WAFD.
La loi interdit la constitution de partis
fondés sur des concepts religieux ou de classe.
Ce qui explique l'absence de listes
islamistes ou communistes.
Le système judiciaire est largement
inspiré de celui de la France.
Les tribunaux bénéficient d'une large
indépendance et la loi garantit à la défense,
le respect de ses droits et la possibilité
de se pourvoir en appel.
L'armée égyptienne se compose d'une
force terrestre de 300 000 hommes,
D'une défense anti-aérienne de 80 000 hommes,
D'une aviation de 29 000 hommes
et d'une marine de 20 000 hommes.
Les équipements militaires sont
fournis par la France, l'Italie,
La Grande-Bretagne, la Chine
et les États-Unis.
Les Égyptiens disposent encore d'un grand
nombre de blindés fournis dans les années 50,
Par l'ex-Union soviétique.
Mais ce matériel est aujourd'hui
largement dépassé.
Les deux tiers de l'industrie
sont propriété de l'état.
Mais le secteur privé est en expansion.
Beaucoup de petites et moyennes
entreprises éprouvent des difficultés,
À concurrencer les productions
subventionnées par le gouvernement,
Qui exerce un sévère contrôle des prix.
Le commerce de détail, le secteur tertiaire
et celui de la construction,
Sont très largement privatisés,
de même que l'agriculture,
Administrée par des coopératives
locales qui sont néanmoins tenus,
de respecter des normes de production.
La quasi totalité des terres agricoles
est concentré sur 35 000 kilomètres carrés,
De terres fertiles dans la vallée du Nil
et la région du delta.
Certains sols désertiques ont été fertilisés,
mais d'autres, qui étaient cultivables,
Ont été sacrifiés à l'urbanisation.
Plus d'un tiers de la main
d'oeuvre travaille aux champs.
Et si on y ajoute celle qui est utilisée
dans les usines de transformation,
Et dans le commerce de produits agricoles,
Ce sont 45 à 50% de la population égyptienne,
Qui vivent des produits de la terre.
Le niveau de productivité
est exceptionnellement élevé.
Le climat et le barrage d'Assouan,
Qui permettent une irrigation
intense et régularisée,
Offrent la possibilité
de plusieurs récoltes par an.
Principales productions les haricots, le riz
et surtout le coton d'excellente qualité,
mais aussi le maïs, l'orge,
les oignons, les citrons.
Par contre, la production
de céréales est en déficit.
L'égypte importe des États-Unis et d'autres
pays occidentaux de grandes quantités de blé.
Parmi les ressources naturelles du pays
autres que l'agriculture, les phosphates,
Le minerai de fer et les gisements
de pétrole du golfe de Suez.
Au milieu des années 80,
l'effondrement des cours pétroliers,
Aggravés par un processus beaucoup trop
lent d'adaptation aux tarifs de la concurrence,
A nui gravement à la balance commerciale.
Alors que le secteur avait
bénéficié d'importants investissements,
La production pétrolière
a dû être contingentée.
Les prix s'étant stabilisés, les exploitations
sont cependant redevenues rentables.
Aujourd'hui, le pétrole offre à l'Égypte
les deux tiers de ses revenus à l'exportation,
Et représente 14% de
son produit national brut.
Sont par contre en baisse
les revenus du tourisme,
Malgré l'effort fourni en matière d'hôtellerie,
Et ceux du trafic sur le canal de Suez.
L'Egypte est le pays le plus scolarisé du
Proche-Orient, avec 40% d'alphabétisation.
L'enseignement est gratuit,
y compris à l'université.
Et beaucoup d'Égyptiens sont recrutés à
l'étranger comme cadres ou travailleurs spécialisés.
40 000 diplômés sortent chaque
année des hautes écoles,
Fréquentées à 46% par des femmes.
Le taux de chômage est faible.
Le manque de main d'œuvre constitue d'ailleurs,
avec l'inflation et la dette extérieure,
Le point noir de l'économie.
Sur une superficie double
de celle de la France,
1 million de kilomètres carrés,
vivaient lors du recensement de 1986,
50 millions d'habitants,
Et le taux de croissance est de 2,6%.
Cela représente une densité moyenne
d'environ 35 habitants au kilomètre carré,
Mais en fait, ils sont plus
de 1000 au kilomètre carré,
Dans la zone fertile d'une vingtaine
de kilomètres de large qui borde le Nil,
De la frontière soudanaise au delta.
Quant à la capitale, Le Caire,
Elle héberge 5 millions d'habitants.
Et même plus de 13 millions si on comptabilise
ceux qui peuplent les faubourgs,
Et les travailleurs migrants non déclarés.
90% de cette population
est composée de Hamites,
Autochtones de très vieille souche.
Les 10% restants sont des Grecs, des
Italiens, des syro-libanais, des Juifs,
Des nomades bédouins et des Nubiens.
Le Caire est la ville la plus peuplée
d'Afrique et du monde arabe.
Née sur la rive orientale du Nil,
Elle s'étend maintenant de part
et d'autre du fleuve,
Partagé entre les influences occidentales
et les quartiers anciens,
Parcourus d'un fourmillement humain où s'entassent
les témoignages prestigieux de son passé.
L'urbanisation croissante qui fait se presser
dans la ceinture populaire de la capitale,
Jusqu'à 60 000 habitants au kilomètre carré,
A profondément modifié
la cellule familiale.
Pendant des siècles, les Égyptiens ont vécu
en communauté, rassemblant sous un même toit,
deux ou trois générations
et toute leur parenté.
Aujourd'hui, les cohabitants
sont peu nombreux,
Un homme, sa femme
et les enfants encore célibataires.
Les aînés sont l'objet
d'un grand respect,
Et leurs enfants sont tenus de veiller
personnellement à leur bien être.
L'idée de placer un parent âgé dans
une maison de retraite est ici impensable.
Aux parents le soin de choisir pour leur
enfant une profession, une école,
Et même un conjoint.
C'est pour les Égyptiens la garantie
d'une sécurité émotive,
À laquelle ils attachent
le plus grand prix.
Le Caire est considéré de longue date
comme un des foyers de la culture arabe,
Et de sa promotion.
La production cinématographique
y est très importante,
Et on y publie six journaux quotidiens
qui tirent à plus de 2 millions d'exemplaires,
Quatorze revues hebdomadaires
et de nombreux mensuels.
Chaque formation politique
édite sa propre publication.
Le président Nasser avait très tôt
pris conscience de l'importance,
Dans un pays en voie de développement,
d'une institution de radiodiffusion efficace.
Le Egyptian Broadcasting Corporation, diffuse
aujourd'hui sept chaînes de radio nationales,
Et quatre chaînes internationales qui transmettent
chaque jour 180 heures de programmes,
En 32 langues.
S'y ajoutent deux chaînes de télévision
publiques en constant développement.
Ce n'est pas son incontestable
modernité qui confère à l'Egypte,
La fascination qu'elle continue
d'exercer sur le monde.
Mais l'héritage de ses 5000 ans
d'histoire et de culture.
Ses pyramides, ses temples,
ses monuments et les inestimables
trésors qu'ils renferment.
Tout cela, pourtant,
est plus que jamais menacé,
Beaucoup moins aujourd'hui par le
poids des siècles ou les intempéries,
Que par la face cachée du progrès,
Le tourisme, la pollution.
Le Sphinx lui-même n'est pas
à l'abri de ces périls.
Plus de 4000 ans à la belle étoile,
Et les pires tempêtes de sable
l'ont moins éprouvé,
Que la corrosion qui
le ronge comme une lèpre.
Et la montée de la nappe aquifère
qui mine ses soubassements.
La science s'attache à
le restaurer et, par prudence,
On le photographie sous tous les angles en
prévision d'une disparition pure et simple,
Qu'on s'efforce de différer,
Mais que l'on sait inéluctable.
Tout cela, un jour, cessera d'exister.
C'est une perspective que l'on a envisagée
dès l'entre deux guerres.
Et qui a amené la création
d'associations spécialisées,
Tel l'Institut oriental
de l'Université de Chicago,
Fondé en 1924 par l'égyptologue
américain James Preston.
Ici sont répertoriées des milliers de clichés
et de fac-similés de dessins,
Ou de sculptures antiques déjà disparues.
Le sable sous lequel ils étaient ensevelis,
Avait protégé ses trésors durant des millénaires.
Lorsqu'on les a dégagé,
une réaction chimique s'est produite,
Entre les sels minéraux contenus dans
la pierre et l'humidité de l'air.
La surface des murs s'est morcelée
jusqu'à tomber en poussière.
Ainsi s'est dissoute dans le néant une petite
part de la mémoire humaine.
Au train où vont les choses,
La plupart des peintures et sculptures
que l'on peut encore admirer aujourd'hui,
Auront disparu dans 200 ans.
L'égypte ne souhaite pas pour autant vivre
son histoire à reculons.
Elle s'efforce de préserver son passé,
Et de continuer à en tirer des leçons
de tolérance et de sagesse.
Mais elle est décidée aussi à entrer
de plain pied dans le XXIᵉ siècle.
C'est le pays de tous les contrastes.
C'est la fascination
de la beauté et du mystère.
C'est le prestige de la fierté
et de l'indépendance.
C'est l'Égypte.